This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Speak and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Speak and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show.|||这是一个 I-Heart 播客。有真人品质保证。大家好。我是杰玛·斯皮克（Jemma Speak），欢迎回到《你的二十多岁心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），在这里我们探讨二十多岁时经历的重大变化、重要时刻和转型，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。
Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode and an episode on a topic. we have spoken about so rarely on the podcast that I almost feel a little bit guilty. I almost feel like I haven't done my job properly. We're talking about the unique relationship we have with our siblings and how those dynamics play out in our psychological and also in our emotional worlds. The sibling bond is like no other. Let's just say that.
Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode and an episode on a topic. we have spoken about so rarely on the podcast that I almost feel a little bit guilty. I almost feel like I haven't done my job properly. We're talking about the unique relationship we have with our siblings and how those dynamics play out in our psychological and also in our emotional worlds. The sibling bond is like no other. Let's just say that.|||欢迎再次收听本播客。很高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目，这一期我们要聊一个在节目中极少涉及的话题，以至于我几乎感到有点内疚。我甚至觉得自己没有把工作做好。我们要讨论的是我们与兄弟姐妹之间的独特关系，以及这些动态如何在我们心理和情感世界中发挥作用。手足之情是独一无二的。我们只能这么说。
But just because it is special doesn't mean that it's immune to the problems that I guess all close relationships have. There's also different levels of closeness for everyone, right? You might be listening to this and have an amazing relationship with your siblings that, you know, you might think of them as soulmates. You might be listening to this and have the complete opposite, where there is distance, intention, and disagreement. What shapes this is often very complicated and comes from a mix of personality, lifestyle, environment, but probably most importantly, upbringing and parental environment. There was a very famous saying that two children can be raised in the same house, same family,
But just because it is special doesn't mean that it's immune to the problems that I guess all close relationships have. There's also different levels of closeness for everyone, right? You might be listening to this and have an amazing relationship with your siblings that, you know, you might think of them as soulmates. You might be listening to this and have the complete opposite, where there is distance, intention, and disagreement. What shapes this is often very complicated and comes from a mix of personality, lifestyle, environment, but probably most importantly, upbringing and parental environment. There was a very famous saying that two children can be raised in the same house, same family,|||但这并不意味着它能免疫所有亲密关系都会有的问题。而且每个人的亲密程度也不同，对吧？你可能在听这期节目时，和兄弟姐妹的关系好得不得了，把他们视作灵魂伴侣。你也可能听了之后觉得完全相反，彼此之间存在距离、意图分歧和不和。塑造这种关系的因素往往非常复杂，由性格、生活方式、环境交织而成，但可能最重要的是成长经历和父母所提供的环境。有句非常著名的话说，两个孩子可以在同一所房子、同一个家庭中抚养长大，
and have completely different childhoods. And that's what I kind of want to discuss today, primarily through the lens of sibling rivalry and the competition we often have with our siblings, from children to adults. As kids, you know, this rivalry seems kind of petty, but as we get older and in our 20s especially, there's definitely a turning point where we start to understand some of the more nefarious things that influence how well we get along with our brothers and sisters, from parental favoritism to birth order, childhood roles, parental conflict, and so much more. So in today's episode, we're going to talk about it.
and have completely different childhoods. And that's what I kind of want to discuss today, primarily through the lens of sibling rivalry and the competition we often have with our siblings, from children to adults. As kids, you know, this rivalry seems kind of petty, but as we get older and in our 20s especially, there's definitely a turning point where we start to understand some of the more nefarious things that influence how well we get along with our brothers and sisters, from parental favoritism to birth order, childhood roles, parental conflict, and so much more. So in today's episode, we're going to talk about it.|||却有着截然不同的童年。这正是我今天要探讨的，主要通过手足竞争的视角，以及我们从小到大常常与兄弟姐妹产生的竞争。小时候，这种竞争似乎显得有些微不足道，但随着我们年龄的增长，特别是在二十多岁的时候，绝对会出现一个转折点，让我们开始理解那些影响我们与兄弟姐妹相处融洽程度的更深层次的因素，从父母的偏心到出生顺序、童年角色、父母冲突等等。所以在今天的节目中，我们要好好谈谈这个。
We're finally going to shine a light on sibling relationships, specifically sibling rivalry. Let's get into it. Okay, before we get into how sibling relationships can become twisted and complicated and hard, especially as we get older. Let's just start with the easy stuff. Let's start with something more light, which is why our relationship with our siblings is unlike probably any other relationship you will ever have. For starters, if we are lucky enough, 80% of us have siblings.
We're finally going to shine a light on sibling relationships, specifically sibling rivalry. Let's get into it. Okay, before we get into how sibling relationships can become twisted and complicated and hard, especially as we get older. Let's just start with the easy stuff. Let's start with something more light, which is why our relationship with our siblings is unlike probably any other relationship you will ever have. For starters, if we are lucky enough, 80% of us have siblings.|||我们终于要聚焦手足关系，尤其是手足竞争了。我们深入探讨吧。好的，在我们深入探讨手足关系如何变得扭曲、复杂和艰难（特别是随着我们年龄的增长）之前。我们先从轻松的内容开始。我们从一些更轻松的话题切入，那就是为什么我们与兄弟姐妹的关系可能不同于你经历过的任何其他关系。首先，如果我们足够幸运的话，我们之中有 80% 的人都有兄弟姐妹。
And your siblings will probably be the longest relationship you are going to have in your life. They are there with you before you make real friends, before you meet your partners, and often, again, if we're lucky enough, after you lose parents and other close family members, they also, I think, transcend beyond just a friendship, right? They're their own category. You're always going to be tied to each other, no matter how far you may travel, split, drift, and you know what, DNA or not, even if you're adopted, even if you have step siblings, it's the same. It's that intimate childhood environment and those experiences and the fact that you are family and that means something important to us as humans that never goes away and means that your
And your siblings will probably be the longest relationship you are going to have in your life. They are there with you before you make real friends, before you meet your partners, and often, again, if we're lucky enough, after you lose parents and other close family members, they also, I think, transcend beyond just a friendship, right? They're their own category. You're always going to be tied to each other, no matter how far you may travel, split, drift, and you know what, DNA or not, even if you're adopted, even if you have step siblings, it's the same. It's that intimate childhood environment and those experiences and the fact that you are family and that means something important to us as humans that never goes away and means that your|||而且你的兄弟姐妹很可能是你一生中最长久的关系。在你结交真正的朋友之前、在你遇到伴侣之前，他们就在你身边；而且通常情况下，如果我们足够幸运的话，在你失去父母和其他至亲之后，他们依然在。我认为他们甚至超越了单纯的友谊，对吧？他们属于一个独立的类别。无论你们走得多远、分开还是疏远，你们总会彼此相连，你知道吗，不管有没有血缘关系，即使是被收养的，即使有继兄弟姐妹，也是一样的。正是那种亲密的童年环境、那些经历，以及你们是一家人这一事实，对我们人类来说有着永恒的重要意义，这意味着你们的
relationship is always going to be part of who you are. Siblings are also often your first peers, first competitors, first companions, and your first social mirror because they're usually the people that are closest to us both relationally and also in age. There's some amazing things about having siblings for some of those reasons we've mentioned. And I also think fighting with your siblings is also something that's kind of fun about having, you know, having a brother or sister. I know it gets a little bit tricky.
relationship is always going to be part of who you are. Siblings are also often your first peers, first competitors, first companions, and your first social mirror because they're usually the people that are closest to us both relationally and also in age. There's some amazing things about having siblings for some of those reasons we've mentioned. And I also think fighting with your siblings is also something that's kind of fun about having, you5 know, having a brother or sister. I know it gets a little bit tricky.|||关系将永远是你自我的一部分。兄弟姐妹通常也是你的第一批同龄人、第一批竞争对手、第一批伙伴，以及你的第一面社交镜子，因为他们通常是无论在关系上还是在年龄上都离我们最近的人。出于我们提到的某些原因，拥有兄弟姐妹有许多奇妙之处。而且我也认为，和兄弟姐妹吵架也是拥有兄弟或姐妹的一种乐趣所在。我知道这有时会变得有点棘手。
We're going to talk about that. But let's firstly begin with why fighting with your siblings is normal. For a lot of us when we think about brothers and sisters, especially as we fight with them, We think about, you know, arguing about who gets the bigger room, whose turn it was to sit in the front seat, who got more attention at dinner, who always gets away with things, who doesn't. Childhood arguments are important because they are part of like the folklore of family life. And sibling conflict is this really unique type of conflict where you actually sometimes benefit because you pick up some incredible soft skills that you don't even realize. You may take for granted. child development researchers point to this incredible socializing function of sibling rivalry
We're going to talk about that. But let's firstly begin with why fighting with your siblings is normal. For a lot of us when we think about brothers and sisters, especially as we fight with them, We think about, you5 know, arguing about who gets the bigger room, whose turn it was to sit in the front seat, who got more attention at dinner, who always gets away with things, who doesn't. Childhood arguments are important because they are part of like the folklore of family life. And sibling conflict is this really unique type of conflict where you actually sometimes benefit because you pick up some incredible soft skills that you don't even realize. You may take for granted. child development researchers point to this incredible socializing function of sibling rivalry|||我们接下来会谈到这一点。但我们首先从为什么和兄弟姐妹吵架是正常的开始说起。对我们中的许多人来说，当我们在想到兄弟姐妹时，特别是当我们在和他们吵架时，我们会想到，比如，争论谁住更大的房间、轮到谁坐前排座位、谁在晚饭时得到更多关注、谁总能逃脱惩罚、谁不能。童年的争吵很重要，因为它们就像是家庭生活民间传说的一部分。手足冲突是一种非常独特的冲突，有时候你实际上会从中受益，因为你习得了一些连自己都没有意识到的惊人软技能。你可能会认为这是理所当然的。儿童发展研究人员指出，手足竞争具有这种惊人的社交功能，
as why it is necessary for life. Our siblings are some of the greatest and earliest teachers we will ever have. You learn so much about negotiation, retaliation, sharing, fairness, apologizing, boundaries, humor, emotional regulation. The list goes on and on through fighting with your siblings. They're also one of the first places that children and we as humans experience the very human fact that love and hostility can coexist, that love is often complicated. And we often model to each other what is expected in certain scenarios as loved ones in a way that other people can't because it would be wildly inappropriate. You know, think about it.
as why it is necessary for life. Our siblings are some of the greatest and earliest teachers we will ever have. You learn so much about negotiation, retaliation, sharing, fairness, apologizing, boundaries, humor, emotional regulation. The list goes on and on through fighting with your siblings. They're also one of the first places that children and we as humans experience the very human fact that love and hostility can coexist, that love is often complicated. And we often model to each other what is expected in certain scenarios as loved ones in a way that other people can't because it would be wildly inappropriate. You know, think about it.|||这也是它对生活必不可少的原因。我们的兄弟姐妹是我们一生中遇到过的最伟大、最早的老师之一。通过与兄弟姐妹吵架，你可以学到很多关于谈判、报复、分享、公平、道歉、边界、幽默感和情绪调节的知识。这样的例子不胜枚举。它们也是儿童以及作为人类的我们体验“爱与敌意可以共存、爱往往是复杂的”这一非常人类事实的最早场所之一。而且我们经常向彼此示范作为挚爱之人在某些情景下应该有怎样的表现，这种方式是其他人无法做到的，因为那会极其不合时宜。你知道的，仔细想想。
Like, your siblings are often the people who correct your behavior more than your parents do by getting upset at you, by retaliating, by maybe hitting you, crying, that important social feedback. And we allow it because we love them and because we have this bond. You know, another kid biting you in the playground because you annoy them. That is like a tetanus shot and an expulsion. But it's more okay and it's more socially acceptable with siblings, meaning sometimes we just learn quicker through them instead of waiting for society to politely correct us later on.
Like, your siblings are often the people who correct your behavior more than your parents do by getting upset at you, by retaliating, by maybe hitting you, crying, that important social feedback. And we allow it because we love them and because we have this bond. You know, another kid biting you in the playground because you annoy them. That is like a tetanus shot and an expulsion. But it's more okay and it's more socially acceptable with siblings, meaning sometimes we just learn quicker through them instead of waiting for society to politely correct us later on.|||比如，你的兄弟姐妹往往比父母更能通过生你的气、报复你、甚至打你、哭泣来纠正你的行为，提供那种重要的社交反馈。而我们允许这样做，因为我们爱他们，因为我们之间有这种纽带。你知道的，如果游乐场里另一个孩子因为你惹恼了他而咬了你。那简直就像是一针破伤风疫苗加上被开除。但如果是兄弟姐妹这样做，就更可以接受，在社会上也更能被理解，这意味着有时我们通过他们能更快地学到东西，而不必等待社会在以后客气地纠正我们。
There was a 2012 study from Feinberg and colleagues actually that looked closer into the three distinct pathways of influence that our siblings have on our behavior. Here is what they found. Pathway number one, they helped provide a behavioral repertoire. Again, I think I've said this a couple of times now, but like the home is the training ground. So through daily interactions, we tend to teach you other social skills, or conversely coercive behavioursive behaviours as well. If a sibling relationship is defined by aggression and conflict, children can learn that hostility is an effective way to get what you want, which is a habit that they may then carry into their school life and peer groups. But if they learn love and friendship
There was a 2012 study from Feinberg and colleagues actually that looked closer into the three distinct pathways of influence that our siblings have on our behavior. Here is what they found. Pathway number one, they helped provide a behavioral repertoire. Again, I think I've said this a couple of times now, but like the home is the training ground. So through daily interactions, we tend to teach you other social skills, or conversely coercive behavioursive behaviours as well. If a sibling relationship is defined by aggression and conflict, children can learn that hostility is an effective way to get what you want, which is a habit that they may then carry into their school life and peer groups. But if they learn love and friendship|||事实上，范伯格（Feinberg）及其同事在 2012 年进行了一项研究，更深入地探讨了兄弟姐妹对我们行为产生影响的三种不同途径。以下是他们的发现。途径一：他们帮助提供了行为贮备。再说一次，我想我已经说过好几次了，家就是训练场。因此，通过日常互动，我们往往会教给你其他社交技能，或者相反，也会教给你高压或强制性的行为。如果手足关系是由攻击和冲突定义的，孩子们就会学到敌意是获得你想要的东西的有效方式，这种习惯随后可能会被他们带到学校生活和同龄人群体中。但如果他们学到的是爱、友谊
and cooperation, they carry that as well as part of their behavioral repertoire. The second thing that sibling relationships teach us is deviancy training. This is like the partner in crime kind of bond. Beyond just learning general behaviors, siblings often directly model and reinforce specific activities or choices or preferences that influence how we express ourselves, what we wear, what we like, how we act, even risky things like substance use or delinquency as you get older. The paper I'm referring to notes that this is particularly,
and cooperation, they carry that as well as part of their behavioral repertoire. The second thing that sibling relationships teach us is deviancy training. This is like the partner in crime kind of bond. Beyond just learning general behaviors, siblings often directly model and reinforce specific activities or choices or preferences that influence how we express ourselves, what we wear, what we like, how we act, even risky things like substance use or delinquency as you get older. The paper I'm referring to notes that this is particularly,|||和合作，他们也会将这些作为其行为贮备的一部分。手足关系教给我们的第二件事是偏差行为训练。这就像是“共犯”那种纽带。除了学习一般行为之外，兄弟姐妹通常还会直接示范和强化特定的活动、选择或偏好，这些都会影响我们如何表达自己、我们穿什么、我们喜欢什么、我们如何行事，甚至随着年龄增长而产生的诸如物质滥用或越轨行为等高风险事情。我提到的这篇论文指出，这一点尤其明显，
potent because unlike friends, you don't choose your siblings, making their influence unavoidable and a constant presence in your life for good or for bad. Finally, the family system. They teach you what family means. This is where siblings have this kind of ripple effect. Sibling conflict in particular doesn't just stay between the kids but acts as a major stressor for parents and fighting between the parents acts as a major stressor for siblings. It's also within this dynamic that you understand what is expected of people that claim to love you. Yes, with your parents, but also with your siblings, what it means to repair relationships, what it means to expect things from other people. So sibling conflict can also be very brutal. I think I'm speaking
potent because unlike friends, you don't choose your siblings, making their influence unavoidable and a constant presence in your life for good or for bad. Finally, the family system. They teach you what family means. This is where siblings have this kind of ripple effect. Sibling conflict in particular doesn't just stay between the kids but acts as a major stressor for parents and fighting between the parents acts as a major stressor for siblings. It's also within this dynamic that you understand what is expected of people that claim to love you. Yes, with your parents, but also with your siblings, what it means to repair relationships, what it means to expect things from other people. So sibling conflict can also be very brutal. I think I'm speaking|||强效，因为与朋友不同，你无法选择自己的兄弟姐妹，这使得他们的影响不可避免，无论好坏，他们都是你生活中挥之不去的存在。最后，家庭系统。他们教给你家庭意味着什么。这就是兄弟姐妹产生这种连锁反应的地方。特别是手足冲突不仅停留在孩子之间，还会成为父母的主要压力源，而父母之间的争吵也是兄弟姐妹的主要压力源。正是在这种动态中，你才理解了那些声称爱你的人对你的期望是什么。是的，包括对父母，也包括对兄弟姐妹，理解了修复关系意味着什么，对他人抱有期望意味着什么。因此，手足冲突也可能非常残酷。我想我正在谈论的
about the benefits, but it can get really intense, like physically. I have a scar on my arm from when like one of my sisters scratched me over something. I don't even know what. And it gets a lot worse than that. Dr. Mark Feinberg, that same man who did that original paper we were talking about, he investigates sibling relationships a lot at Pennsylvania State University. He's one of the leading names in this research area, and he suggests that sibling rivalry is particularly intense around the period of early to middle childhood. This period of childhood is a key years for sibling aggression and conflict because not only do you spend so much time together during this period, but also you are lacking emotional and social regulation skills that you need
about the benefits, but it can get really intense, like physically. I have a scar on my arm from when like one of my sisters scratched me over something. I don't even know what. And it gets a lot worse than that. Dr. Mark Feinberg, that same man who did that original paper we were talking about, he investigates sibling relationships a lot at Pennsylvania State University. He's one of the leading names in this research area, and he suggests that sibling rivalry is particularly intense around the period of early to middle childhood. This period of childhood is a key years for sibling aggression and conflict because not only do you spend so much time together during this period, but also you are lacking emotional and social regulation skills that you need|||是它的好处，但它有时会变得非常激烈，比如身体上的冲突。我的手臂上有一个疤痕，就是当年我某一个姐姐因为某件事抓伤我留下的。我甚至都不记得是什么事了。而且情况往往比这还要糟糕得多。马克·范伯格（Mark Feinberg）博士，也就是我们刚才讨论的那篇原始论文的作者，他在宾夕法尼亚州立大学对手足关系进行了大量研究。他是该研究领域的领军人物之一，他指出手足竞争在幼儿期到中童期这段时间尤为激烈。童年的这段时期是手足攻击和冲突的关键年份，因为在这段时期里，你们不仅花大量时间在一起，而且你们还缺乏有效解决他人冲突所需的
to effectively resolve conflict with other people, meaning your relationship isn't a pressure cooker. Again, as I said, it might present itself physically. It might present itself as possessiveness, teasing, it might look like, yeah, just like bitter thoughts, but also copying, stealing, trying to adopt some kind of role in the family. And it's this tension in our early years as children that often gets us a designated role as the troublemaker, as the mediator, as the pushover, as the golden child, as the caretaker. Often a lot of our roles, yes, form through daily interactions, they also form through how we fight with each other, how we relate to each other, conflict being a big part of it. Even young children have a sense of fairness, and sibling life
to effectively resolve conflict with other people, meaning your relationship isn't a pressure cooker. Again, as I said, it might present itself physically. It might present itself as possessiveness, teasing, it might look like, yeah, just like bitter thoughts, but also copying, stealing, trying to adopt some kind of role in the family. And it's this tension in our early years as children that often gets us a designated role as the troublemaker, as the mediator, as the pushover, as the golden child, as the caretaker. Often a lot of our roles, yes, form through daily interactions, they also form through how we fight with each other, how we relate to each other, conflict being a big part of it. Even young children have a sense of fairness, and sibling life|||情感和社交调节技能，这意味着你们的关系就是一个高压锅。再次如我所说，它可能会以身体冲突的形式表现出来。它可能表现为占有欲、捉弄，它看起来可能就像是痛苦的想法，但也包括抄袭、偷窃、试图在家庭中扮演某种角色。正是童年早期的这种紧张关系，常常使我们被指定了某个角色：惹事精、调停者、受气包、金童（受宠的孩子）、照顾者。很多时候，我们的角色固然是通过日常互动形成的，但也是通过我们如何互相吵架、如何建立关系而形成的，冲突是其中的很大一部分。甚至连小孩子也有公平感，手足生活
gives them a constant stream of opportunities to compare and figure out who they are based on how they relate to their siblings, but also what parents give each person. So who gets more warmth, more attention, more freedom, more protection, more praise, maybe even more leniency or physical closeness. Part of why that also creates tension is evolutionary. The fact that our parents do not have endless amounts of time and attention to give us, and therefore we are slightly in competition with our siblings at any given time, is what creates conflict. You know, when you're the only child, the time your parents have to give you as much as they can, you're not really sharing it with anybody else other than your other parent or other than their job or things like that.
gives them a constant stream of opportunities to compare and figure out who they are based on how they relate to their siblings, but also what parents give each person. So who gets more warmth, more attention, more freedom, more protection, more praise, maybe even more leniency or physical closeness. Part of why that also creates tension is evolutionary. The fact that our parents do not have endless amounts of time and attention to give us, and therefore we are slightly in competition with our siblings at any given time, is what creates conflict. You know, when you're the only child, the time your parents have to give you as much as they can, you're not really sharing it with anybody else other than your other parent or other than their job or things like that.|||为他们源源不断地提供了比较的机会，让他们根据自己与兄弟姐妹的关系，以及父母给予每个人的东西，来弄清楚自己是谁。所以，谁得到了更多的温暖、更多的关注、更多的自由、更多的保护、更多的赞扬，甚至可能更多的宽容或身体上的亲密。这也产生紧张关系的部分原因在于进化。我们的父母没有无限的时间和精力来给予我们，因此我们在任何时候都与兄弟姐妹处于轻微的竞争状态，这正是产生冲突的原因。你知道的，当你是个独生子女时，父母能给你的时间已经尽可能多了，你真的没有和除了另一个父母、或者他们的工作之类的事情之外的任何人分享这些时间。
But when there is more of you, time is limited, attention is limited, emotional availability, presence is limited. So from an evolutionary perspective, siblings are in this strange dual position. They are both family and their competitors. They benefit from each other's survival, but they're also competing, at least in part, for parental investment. And that means that they start acting in certain ways that they think their parents may like more or that they think may get them ahead in the family unit. And it's not that each sibling is consciously calculating resource allocations at all times in some like mathematical way. But as children, like I said, we're attuned to fairness. We're attuned to who is getting more, who is getting less. If you've been
But when there is more of you, time is limited, attention is limited, emotional availability, presence is limited. So from an evolutionary perspective, siblings are in this strange dual position. They are both family and their competitors. They benefit from each other's survival, but they're also competing, at least in part, for parental investment. And that means that they start acting in certain ways that they think their parents may like more or that they think may get them ahead in the family unit. And it's not that each sibling is consciously calculating resource allocations at all times in some like mathematical way. But as children, like I said, we're attuned to fairness. We're attuned to who is getting more, who is getting less. If you've been|||但当家里孩子变多时，时间是有限的，注意力是有限的，情感的可获得性和陪伴是有限的。因此，从进化的角度来看，兄弟姐妹处于一种奇怪的双重地位。他们既是家人，又是竞争对手。他们从彼此的生存中受益，但他们也在竞争，至少在某种程度上是为了争取父母的投入。这意味着他们开始以某种特定的方式行事，认为父母可能会更喜欢这种方式，或者认为这能让他们在家庭单位中脱颖而出。这并不是说每个兄弟姐妹都在以某种数学方式时刻有意识地计算资源分配。但正如我所说，作为孩子，我们对公平有着敏锐的感知。我们对谁得到的更多、谁得到的更少非常敏感。如果你最近
around kids recently, you know this well. It is like a constant thing that's going on in their mind. So that's another major theory as to why sometimes our relationship with our siblings isn't always great. Unconsciously, it comes from this conflict over parental love and resources that starts as kids, but transforms as adults. I also just think that, like, it's not always about wanting what the other sibling has. It's also simply, like, sometimes we have conflict with our siblings because we just don't want to disappear, and we act out in relation to our siblings because we want to have this distinct identity, right? And as adults, we know that, like, starting fights with our siblings, acting out, like, is
around kids recently, you know this well. It is like a constant thing that's going on in their mind. So that's another major theory as to why sometimes our relationship with our siblings isn't always great. Unconsciously, it comes from this conflict over parental love and resources that starts as kids, but transforms as adults. I also just think that, like, it's not always about wanting what the other sibling has. It's also simply, like, sometimes we have conflict with our siblings because we just don't want to disappear, and we act out in relation to our siblings because we want to have this distinct identity, right? And as adults, we know that, like, starting fights with our siblings, acting out, like, is|||和孩子们接触过，你就会对此深有体会。这就像是他们脑海中一直在进行的事情。所以这是关于为什么有时我们与兄弟姐妹的关系并不总是那么融洽的另一个主要理论。在潜意识里，它源于这种从童年开始、但在成年后发生转变的、对父母爱与资源的争夺冲突。我也只是认为，这并不总是关于想要另一个兄弟姐妹拥有的东西。有时我们与兄弟姐妹发生冲突，也单纯是因为我们不想被忽视，我们针对兄弟姐妹做出一些出格行为，是因为我们想要拥有这种独特的身份，对吧？成年后我们知道，和兄弟姐妹挑起争端、做出出格行为，其实是
annoying and probably wrong. But as children, like, you just want to feel noticed. You just want to feel seen. And there's also just the fact that you guys are different people. People fight with their siblings because you're not the same person. You do have different opinions, preferences, personalities, roles that have been assigned by the family. And other times you, some people just annoy you. It doesn't matter that you're related. Like, you being related doesn't exclude you from this human truth. Other people get on our nerves because they are not us, right? And with our siblings, unlike with some other relationships, but definitely it is an option. Like, you can't just step away and be like, I'm done with that. It's a lot harder. So what I'm saying, to give a mini
annoying and probably wrong. But as children, like, you just want to feel noticed. You just want to feel seen. And there's also just the fact that you guys are different people. People fight with their siblings because you're not the same person. You do have different opinions, preferences, personalities, roles that have been assigned by the family. And other times you, some people just annoy you. It doesn't matter that you're related. Like, you being related doesn't exclude you from this human truth. Other people get on our nerves because they are not us, right? And with our siblings, unlike with some other relationships, but definitely it is an option. Like, you can't just step away and be like, I'm done with that. It's a lot harder. So what I'm saying, to give a mini|||令人讨厌的，而且可能是错的。但作为孩子，你只是想被注意到。你只是想被看见。此外还有一个事实，你们是不同的人。人们和兄弟姐妹吵架，是因为你们不是同一个人。你们确实有不同的意见、偏好、性格，以及被家庭赋予的不同角色。还有的时候，有些人就是会惹你生气。这和你们是否有血缘关系无关。你们有血缘关系并不能让你免于这一人类真理。其他人惹恼我们，是因为他们不是我们，对吧？而对于兄弟姐妹，与某些其他关系不同，尽管这绝对是一种选择，你不能直接一走了之说：“我受够了，不管了。”这要难得多。所以我想说的是，做一个小小的
summary of this section, sibling rivalry in childhood is normal. It is a socially experimental way of learning certain skills. It, it is. It, it. is how we, you know, gain parental love or feel like we matter or we are seen in the family. It can also take a turn, especially as we get older. So let's talk about how sibling rivalry transforms in adulthood and maybe becomes complicated after this short break. Listen and you're there for heart-wrenching knockout. And breathtaking triumph. In 2026 FIFA World Cup.
summary of this section, sibling rivalry in childhood is normal. It is a socially experimental way of learning certain skills. It, it is. It, it. is how we, you know, gain parental love or feel like we matter or we are seen in the family. It can also take a turn, especially as we get older. So let's talk about how sibling rivalry transforms in adulthood and maybe becomes complicated after this short break. Listen and you're there for heart-wrenching knockout. And breathtaking triumph. In 2026 FIFA World Cup.|||本节总结，童年时期的手足竞争是正常的。它是学习某些技能的一种社交实验方式。它就是这样。它就是我们如何获得父母的爱，或者在家庭中感觉自己很重要、被看见的方式。它也可能会发生转变，特别是在我们年龄渐长之后。因此，在短暂的休息之后，我们来谈谈手足竞争在成年后是如何转变并变得复杂的。倾听，你将见证心碎的淘汰。以及惊心动魄的胜利。在 2026 年国际足联世界杯上。
The knockout stage. Every match, every moment. Listen on TSN Radio. Join the globe on the road to the July 19th final. 2026 FIFA World Cup. Stream it all live on TSN Radio. Available on IHeard Radio. In adulthood, especially in our 20s,
The knockout stage. Every match, every moment. Listen on TSN Radio. Join the globe on the road to the July 19th final. 2026 FIFA World Cup. Stream it all live on TSN Radio. Available on IHeard Radio. In adulthood, especially in our 20s,|||淘汰赛阶段。每一场比赛，每一个瞬间。在 TSN 电台收听。与全球一起走上通往 7 月 19 日决赛的道路。2026 年国际足联世界杯。在 TSN 电台全程直播。可在 IHeard Radio 上收听。在成年期，特别是在我们的二十多岁时，
I think sibling, this is going to sound obvious, sibling competition is not about who gets what in terms of toys or front seats. It becomes very psychological. It becomes more about status, achievement, closeness to parents, pride, coping, and also the past and who is carrying things from the past with them, just to name a few. The developmental literature on sibling relationships in the transition from teenage years to adulthood shows that sibling relationships often shift significantly around this time in line with wider life transitions, like leaving home, getting a partner, working, studying, marrying,
I think sibling, this is going to sound obvious, sibling competition is not about who gets what in terms of toys or front seats. It becomes very psychological. It becomes more about status, achievement, closeness to parents, pride, coping, and also the past and who is carrying things from the past with them, just to name a few. The developmental literature on sibling relationships in the transition from teenage years to adulthood shows that sibling relationships often shift significantly around this time in line with wider life transitions, like leaving home, getting a partner, working, studying, marrying,|||我认为手足竞争——这听起来可能很显而易见——不再是关于谁在玩具或前排座位上得到了什么。它变得非常心理化。它更多地关于地位、成就、与父母的亲密程度、自豪感、应对方式，还有过去以及谁带着过去的事情一起前行，这只是其中的几个例子。关于从青少年时期向成年期过渡中手足关系的发展文献表明，手足关系往往在这段时间里发生显著变化，这与更广泛的人生转折相吻合，比如离家、寻找伴侣、工作、学习、结婚、
becoming a parent. Things do start to change that take away or maybe improve the original sibling relationship. I've seen it in many, many cases that friends of mine have actually gotten so much closer with their brothers and sisters as they age because these huge life changes give them a more grounded, more kind of well-rounded perspective on priorities. Maybe it's the first time in their lives that they really like understand each other because they need each other more. But I've also found, you know, people get less close with their siblings as they get older. And that's been my case. You know, me and my younger sisters have a pretty big age gap, I would say. I moved out when I was
becoming a parent. Things do start to change that take away or maybe improve the original sibling relationship. I've seen it in many, many cases that friends of mine have actually gotten so much closer with their brothers and sisters as they age because these huge life changes give them a more grounded, more kind of well-rounded perspective on priorities. Maybe it's the first time in their lives that they really like understand each other because they need each other more. But I've also found, you know, people get less close with their siblings as they get older. And that's been my case. You know, me and my younger sisters have a pretty big age gap, I would say. I moved out when I was|||为人父母。有些事情确实开始改变，这些改变可能会削弱也可能会改善原本的手足关系。我在许许多多的案例中看到，我的朋友们随着年龄的增长，实际上与兄弟姐妹变得更加亲密了，因为这些巨大的生活变迁赋予了他们一种更接地气、更全面的关于轻重缓急的视角。这或许是他们生命中第一次真正像这样相互理解，因为他们比以往任何时候都更需要彼此。但我也发现，你知道的，随着年龄的增长，有些人与兄弟姐妹的关系变得疏远了。我的情况就是如此。你知道的，我和我的几个妹妹年龄差距挺大的，可以说是这样。我搬出去的时候我
17 and they were like nine and 12. They had their whole teenage years together and I wasn't at home. I wasn't even in the same state, let alone the same country. And that creates a different dynamic as you get older. You know, you're never going to be as close as you were when you were living in the same household. And it's not just distance. Sibling relationships can also become distinctively more loaded. The older we get. There's almost this compounding effect where childhood problems and conflicts now compound on top of each other, on top of each other, on top of each other until it becomes years of resentment. By the time you're 25 or 35 or 45, you're not just reacting to one rude comment at Christmas and that's not why you're annoyed at your sibling.
17 and they were like nine and 12. They had their whole teenage years together and I wasn't at home. I wasn't even in the same state, let alone the same country. And that creates a different dynamic as you get older. You're never going to be as close as you were when you were living in the same household. And it's not just distance. Sibling relationships can also become distinctively more loaded. The older we get. There's almost this compounding effect where childhood problems and conflicts now compound on top of each other, on top of each other, on top of each other until it becomes years of resentment. By the time you're 25 or 35 or 45, you're not just reacting to one rude comment at Christmas and that's not why you're annoyed at your sibling.|||17 岁，而她们大约 9 岁和 12 岁。她们一起度过了整个青少年时期，而我不在家。我甚至都不在同一个州，更不用说同一个国家了。随着年龄的增长，这会产生一种不同的动态关系。你们永远不会像住在同一个屋檐下时那么亲密了。而且这不仅仅是距离的问题。随着年龄的增长，手足关系也可能会变得明显更加沉重。几乎存在一种复合效应，童年的问题和冲突现在层层叠加，压在彼此身上，日积月累，直到变成长年的怨恨。当你 25 岁、35 岁或 45 岁时，你对圣诞节上一句粗鲁评论的反应，不仅仅是因为那一句话，那也不是你生兄弟姐妹气的原因。
You're reacting to 20 years of being cast in a certain role with your siblings. Or you're reacting to 20 years of small things that have gone unsaid. You also become more aware of the harmful narratives within your family and the way your parents treated you differently that are hard to ignore as you gain more self-awareness and you gain perhaps more self-respect. Essentially, adult sibling conflict is a container for much, much older wounds, which is why they become a very big battleground for many people in adulthood. Where does this tension begin? We've talked about some of the explanations for why we fight In general, but why do some people walk away from their sibling relationships feeling like things are very unfair?
You're reacting to 20 years of being cast in a certain role with your siblings. Or you're reacting to 20 years of small things that have gone unsaid. You also become more aware of the harmful narratives within your family and the way your parents treated you differently that are hard to ignore as you gain more self-awareness and you gain perhaps more self-respect. Essentially, adult sibling conflict is a container for much, much older wounds, which is why they become a very big battleground for many people in adulthood. Where does this tension begin? We've talked about some of the explanations for why we fight In general, but why do some people walk away from their sibling relationships feeling like things are very unfair?|||你是在对二十年来自己在兄弟姐妹中被赋予的某种角色做出反应。或者说，你是在对二十年来那些未曾说出口的小事情做出反应。随着你获得更多的自我觉察，或许也获得了更多的自尊，你也变得更加意识到家庭中那些有害的叙事，以及父母对你区别对待的方式，这些是很难忽视的。从本质上讲，成年后的手足冲突承载着历史悠久得多的创伤，这就是为什么它们在许多成年人眼中成了一个巨大的战场。这种紧张关系从何开始？我们已经讨论过关于我们为什么通常会吵架的一些解释，但为什么有些人离开手足关系时会觉得事情非常不公平？
One place we can naturally go to is birth order. Now, birth order has its skeptics, and I'm occasionally one of them, but for this, for sibling conflict, birth order makes a lot of sense. There's a few stereotypes we have in popular culture about which sibling acts in which ways. You know, older children are more responsible, but also more bossy. Middle children are the forgotten ones. youngest children are spoiled. It goes deeper than that though, starting with the eldest. The first child enters an empty family system and often carries the parents' fantasies
One place we can naturally go to is birth order. Now, birth order has its skeptics, and I'm occasionally one of them, but for this, for sibling conflict, birth order makes a lot of sense. There's a few stereotypes we have in popular culture about which sibling acts in which ways. You know, older children are more responsible, but also more bossy. Middle children are the forgotten ones. youngest children are spoiled. It goes deeper than that though, starting with the eldest. The first child enters an empty family system and often carries the parents' fantasies|||我们自然而然可以想到的一个切入点是出生顺序。当然，出生顺序有其怀疑论者，我偶尔也是其中之一，但对于手足冲突而言，出生顺序确实很有道理。流行文化中关于哪个兄弟姐妹会有什么样行为的表现，存在一些刻板印象。你知道的，较大的孩子更有责任感，但也更专横。中间的孩子是被遗忘的一群。最小的孩子被娇惯。不过，情况比这更深入，让我们从老大开始说起。第一个孩子进入一个空白的家庭系统，往往承载着父母的幻想，
of getting it right, meaning there's a lot of pressure and a lot more fear and anxiety on their shoulders. You know, raising the eldest to the book whilst also battling the tension of becoming a parent and experiencing something new puts a lot of pressure on a kid even unconsciously. This can mean as we age the eldest feels resentment towards their younger siblings because maybe they didn't get their parents in that high-stress state. Maybe they got it easier. The choices of the parents unconsciously or consciously become reflected in the relationships
of getting it right, meaning there's a lot of pressure and a lot more fear and anxiety on their shoulders. You know, raising the eldest to the book whilst also battling the tension of becoming a parent and experiencing something new puts a lot of pressure on a kid even unconsciously. This can mean as we age the eldest feels resentment towards their younger siblings because maybe they didn't get their parents in that high-stress state. Maybe they got it easier. The choices of the parents unconsciously or consciously become reflected in the relationships|||即“把孩子培养好”，这意味着他们肩负着巨大的压力以及更多的恐惧和焦虑。你知道的，按照育儿书把老大养大，同时还要应对初为人父人母的紧张感并体验新鲜事物，这在无意中给孩子施加了很大的压力。这意味着随着年龄的增长，老大可能会对弟妹产生怨恨，因为也许弟妹没有经历父母那种高压状态。也许弟妹们过得更容易。父母的选择在无意或有意中，通过压力、焦虑和期望，反映在了兄弟姐妹的关系中。
of the siblings through stress, anxiety and expectations. Now the second child enters an already established family system. Your parents have likely naturally already learnt some lessons, made some mistakes, got rid of a bit of anxiety, and that can at times maybe make it feel like less effort is put into the childhood of the middle or second child. This is, I think, especially the case for the middle child. So if your parents end up having more siblings after you, you know, the dominant force of the eldest and the dominant force of the youngest can create a kind of cushioning effect for the middle children. Any younger siblings, specifically youngest, are born into a family where your parents are probably already exhausted and busy.
of the siblings through stress, anxiety and expectations. Now the second child enters an already established family system. Your parents have likely naturally already learnt some lessons, made some mistakes, got rid of a bit of anxiety, and that can at times maybe make it feel like less effort is put into the childhood of the middle or second child. This is, I think, especially the case for the middle child. So if your parents end up having more siblings after you, you know, the dominant force of the eldest and the dominant force of the youngest can create a kind of cushioning effect for the middle children. Any younger siblings, specifically youngest, are born into a family where your parents are probably already exhausted and busy.|||现在，第二个孩子进入了一个已经建立好的家庭系统。你的父母可能已经自然而然地吸取了一些教训、犯了一些错误、消除了部分焦虑，这有时可能会让人觉得父母在中间孩子或老二的童年上投入的精力更少。我认为中间的孩子尤其如此。所以，如果你的父母在你之后还生了更多的孩子，你知道的，老大的主导力量和老么的主导力量可以为中间的孩子起到一种缓冲作用。任何较小的兄弟姐妹，尤其是老么，出生在一个父母可能已经筋疲力尽、十分忙碌的家庭中。
Older children have been given more responsibility. Younger children may receive more indulgence or less monitoring. Middle children may end up negotiating their identity in between these two established positions. It just gets messy. And it's why as you get older, you might be like, that's unfair, even though it's not your siblings' fault they are the way they are. It's birth order. And it's not to say birth order determines who you are inherently, but it does change how you relate to your siblings based on roles that have been forced upon you based on your parents' emotions.
Older children have been given more responsibility. Younger children may receive more indulgence or less monitoring. Middle children may end up negotiating their identity in between these two established positions. It just gets messy. And it's why as you get older, you might be like, that's unfair, even though it's not your siblings' fault they are the way they are. It's birth order. And it's not to say birth order determines who you are inherently, but it does change how you relate to your siblings based on roles that have been forced upon you based on your parents' emotions.|||较大的孩子被赋予了更多的责任。较小的孩子可能会得到更多的纵容或更少的监管。中间的孩子可能最终在这两个既定立场之间摸索和协商自己的身份。事情就是这样变得一团糟。这也是为什么随着年龄的增长，你可能会觉得“这太不公平了”，尽管兄弟姐妹变成这样并不是他们的错。这是出生顺序造成的。这并不是说出生顺序从根本上决定了你是谁，但它确实改变了你与兄弟姐妹的相处方式——根据父母的情绪强加给你的角色。
Parents and families, like, this is a key thing we keep coming back to that creates conflict between siblings. Like, they kind of decide who we are. Like, especially when we're young, we get a role. Like, the ideas our parents have about who we are becomes quite firm because it's based on their own experiences, their own. internal worlds, which often remain a mystery to us, and are incredibly influential on how we see ourselves and our siblings. There's another big contributor here to sibling rivalry beyond the roles we're assigned, which is parental favoritism. It's an age-old question. Kind of a joke at this point, like, do parents have favorites? It's kind of cheeky to admit you do. Or like funny to say like,
Parents and families, like, this is a key thing we keep coming back to that creates conflict between siblings. Like, they kind of decide who we are. Like, especially when we're young, we get a role. Like, the ideas our parents have about who we are becomes quite firm because it's based on their own experiences, their own. internal worlds, which often remain a mystery to us, and are incredibly influential on how we see ourselves and our siblings. There's another big contributor here to sibling rivalry beyond the roles we're assigned, which is parental favoritism. It's an age-old question. Kind of a joke at this point, like, do parents have favorites? It's kind of cheeky to admit you do. Or like funny to say like,|||父母和家庭，就像我们一直回过头来讨论的一个关键问题，是它造成了兄弟姐妹之间的冲突。比如，他们某种程度上决定了我们是谁。比如，特别是当我们年轻时，我们被分配了一个角色。比如，父母对我们是谁的看法变得相当坚定，因为这是基于他们自己的经验、他们自己的内心世界——这些对我们来说往往是个谜——并且对我们如何看待自己和兄弟姐妹有着难以置信的影响力。除了我们被分配的角色之外，这里还有另一个导致手足竞争的重要因素，那就是父母的偏心。这是一个老生常谈的问题。到了这个时候，这甚至有点像个笑话，比如，父母有偏心的孩子吗？承认自己偏心显得有点厚颜无耻。或者开玩笑说，
oh, I don't have a favorite, like, but if I did, it would be you, wink, wink. Like, parents like to joke about it. Maybe they don't joke about it at all, meaning that it seems like they probably do have a favorite. And they forget that this stuff is serious. Firstly, it's serious for how kids relate to their parents, and it is really tragic for how kids relate to their siblings, especially as adults. A lot of research talks about this. Let's clear this up, first and foremost, research does say, parents do have favorites. Full stop. Parents have favorites. An article published just this year by the American Psychological Association. reviewed 30 peer-reviewed journal articles, encompassing almost 20,000 participants,
oh, I don't have a favorite, like, but if I did, it would be you, wink, wink. Like, parents like to joke about it. Maybe they don't joke about it at all, meaning that it seems like they probably do have a favorite. And they forget that this stuff is serious. Firstly, it's serious for how kids relate to their parents, and it is really tragic for how kids relate to their siblings, especially as adults. A lot of research talks about this. Let's clear this up, first and foremost, research does say, parents do have favorites. Full stop. Parents have favorites. An article published just this year by the American Psychological Association. reviewed 30 peer-reviewed journal articles, encompassing almost 20,000 participants,|||“哦，我没有偏心的孩子，不过非要说有的话，那就是你啦，眨眼。”父母喜欢拿这个开玩笑。也许他们根本不开玩笑，这意味着他们看起来确实可能有偏心的孩子。而他们却忘了这些事情是很严肃的。首先，这对孩子与父母的关系来说是严肃的，对孩子与兄弟姐妹的关系来说则是一场彻头彻尾的悲剧，特别是到了成年之后。许多研究都探讨过这一点。让我们首先厘清这一点：研究确实表明，父母确实有偏心的孩子。句号。父母就是有偏心的孩子。美国心理学会（American Psychological Association）今年刚发表的一篇文章审查了 30 篇同行评审的期刊文章，涵盖了近 2 万名参与者，
and found that overall, the majority of parents show preferential treatment, specifically for their daughters, for children who are more organized and introverted, and for the older children. This favoritism is shown in a few ways, so they may interact with these children more, they spend more money on them, they're more kind and positive to that child. To be honest, this deserves an entire episode because this really fucks people up. Like, it has a long-term influence on our sense of self and our self-esteem. But for today's episode, let's just examine it in relation to our siblings.
and found that overall, the majority of parents show preferential treatment, specifically for their daughters, for children who are more organized and introverted, and for the older children. This favoritism is shown in a few ways, so they may interact with these children more, they spend more money on them, they're more kind and positive to that child. To be honest, this deserves an entire episode because this really fucks people up. Like, it has a long-term influence on our sense of self and our self-esteem. But for today's episode, let's just examine it in relation to our siblings.|||发现总体而言，大多数父母都表现出偏爱，具体表现为偏爱女儿、更有条理且内向的孩子，以及较大的孩子。这种偏心主要体现在几个方面：他们可能会与这些孩子更多的互动，在他们身上花更多的钱，对那个孩子更善良、更积极。说实话，这个话题值得单独做一整期节目，因为它真的会把人折腾得够呛。比如，它会对我们的自我意识和自尊产生长期的影响。但对于今天的节目，我们只结合兄弟姐妹的关系来探讨它。
Decades of research on parental differential or favoritism or treatment shows that when children perceive one sibling as receiving more warmth, more support, money, freedom, approval, it tends to be associated with worse outcomes for the less favoured sibling and poorer sibling relationship quality overall. And the impacts aren't only felt in childhood that felt primarily actually in adulthood. A study of young adult siblings found that siblings who felt less loved than a brother or a sister they had reported more depressive symptoms. And people who said their parents had had a greater level of favoritism towards a different child, also showed less intimacy with their siblings, because it's hard to be friendly with someone, even somebody who is a blood relative who you love, when you are constantly convinced and told that they are better than you.
Decades of research on parental differential or favoritism or treatment shows that when children perceive one sibling as receiving more warmth, more support, money, freedom, approval, it tends to be associated with worse outcomes for the less favoured sibling and poorer sibling relationship quality overall. And the impacts aren't only felt in childhood that felt primarily actually in adulthood. A study of young adult siblings found that siblings who felt less loved than a brother or a sister they had reported more depressive symptoms. And people who said their parents had had a greater level of favoritism towards a different child, also showed less intimacy with their siblings, because it's hard to be friendly with someone, even somebody who is a blood relative who you love, when you are constantly convinced and told that they are better than you.|||数十年来关于父母差异对待或偏心的研究表明，当孩子察觉到某一个兄弟姐妹获得了更多的温暖、支持、金钱、自由和认可时，这往往与不受偏爱的那个孩子更差的结果以及较差的整体手足关系质量相关。而且这些影响不仅在童年期能感受到，实际上主要是在成年期才能感受到。一项针对年轻成年手足的研究发现，那些觉得自己不如兄弟或姐妹受宠的手足报告了更多的抑郁症状。那些说父母对另一个孩子偏心程度更高的成年人，与兄弟姐妹之间的亲密感也较低，因为当你总是被灌输并被告知对方比你更好时，要对一个人（哪怕是有血缘关系的你所爱的人）保持友好是非常困难的。
A further 2014 study looking at siblings specifically in later life also found that sibling closeness in adulthood is driven by two specific patterns. The researchers analyzed over 2,000 sibling pairs and discovered this. First, there is a gravitation towards the favorite. People actually reported being closest to the sibling that they could tell was their mother's favorite, even if they weren't the favorite themselves. So one child gets more attention, not just from the parent, but from their other siblings. It's called the golden child effect. This child ends up as the hub for the parents, but also keeps the siblings connected as well. second, they found a distancing from the disfavored sibling.
A further 2014 study looking at siblings specifically in later life also found that sibling closeness in adulthood is driven by two specific patterns. The researchers analyzed over 2,000 sibling pairs and discovered this. First, there is a gravitation towards the favorite. People actually reported being closest to the sibling that they could tell was their mother's favorite, even if they weren't the favorite themselves. So one child gets more attention, not just from the parent, but from their other siblings. It's called the golden child effect. This child ends up as the hub for the parents, but also keeps the siblings connected as well. second, they found a distancing from the disfavored sibling.|||2014 年的另一项专门针对晚年手足的研究还发现，成年后的手足亲密感由两种特定的模式驱动。研究人员分析了 2000 多对手足对，发现了这一点。首先，人们会被那个最受宠的孩子所吸引。人们实际上报告说，他们与自己能看出是母亲最偏爱的那个兄弟姐妹最亲密，即使他们自己并不是那个最受宠的孩子。因此，一个孩子不仅从父母那里获得更多关注，还从其他兄弟姐妹那里获得更多关注。这被称为“金童效应”（the golden child effect）。这个孩子最终成了父母的纽带核心，同时也让兄弟姐妹之间保持着联系。其次，他们发现人们会与不受宠的兄弟姐妹保持距离。
And again, people could tell, even though parents say we don't have a favorite, siblings knew they were significantly less likely to feel close to a brother or sister who was perceived as being less liked by their mother. And what they really saw was that the mother's preferences act as a social signal for the rest of the family. Her favorite becomes the person everyone wants to be around. her least favorite often is the one that finds themselves socially sidelined by their own siblings as well and dealing with more of those emotional and mental consequences. There is also some fascinating nuance here around fairness.
And again, people could tell, even though parents say we don't have a favorite, siblings knew they were significantly less likely to feel close to a brother or sister who was perceived as being less liked by their mother. And what they really saw was that the mother's preferences act as a social signal for the rest of the family. Her favorite becomes the person everyone wants to be around. her least favorite often is the one that finds themselves socially sidelined by their own siblings as well and dealing with more of those emotional and mental consequences. There is also some fascinating nuance here around fairness.|||同样，人们一眼就能看出——尽管父母嘴上说“我们没有偏心的孩子”——但兄弟姐妹心里清楚，对于那些被认为不受母亲喜爱的兄弟或姐妹，他们明显不太可能与之感到亲密。他们真正看到的是，母亲的偏好充当了整个家庭的社会信号。她最喜欢的孩子成了每个人都想靠近的人；而她最不喜欢的孩子往往会发现自己不仅被父母边缘化，还被自己的兄弟姐妹在社交上边缘化，并不得不应对更多由此带来的情感和心理后果。这里围绕公平性还有一些耐人寻味的细微差别。
Some studies suggest that differential treatment is not always equally harmful if children understand that it is fair and justified. So an important caveat here is that if a sibling seems like the favorite because they need more attention, due to a medical issue or a crisis, children often understand that. That changes the dynamic slightly. What does damage is not difference itself, but unexplained differences. So sly preferences, being made to feel like one child is just easier to love, which eventually means we turn the spotlight back on ourselves and start thinking, like, why aren't I easy to love? Why aren't I love that way? It must be something about me, about who I am intrinsically. It also must be something about them, that makes them better than me, well, I obviously don't want to be around them and feel terrible
Some studies suggest that differential treatment is not always equally harmful if children understand that it is fair and justified. So an important caveat here is that if a sibling seems like the favorite because they need more attention, due to a medical issue or a crisis, children often understand that. That changes the dynamic slightly. What does damage is not difference itself, but unexplained differences. So sly preferences, being made to feel like one child is just easier to love, which eventually means we turn the spotlight back on ourselves and start thinking, like, why aren't I easy to love? Why aren't I love that way? It must be something about me, about who I am intrinsically. It also must be something about them, that makes them better than me, well, I obviously don't want to be around them and feel terrible|||一些研究表明，如果孩子们理解这种差异对待是公平且正当的，那么差异对待并不总是具有同等程度的伤害性。因此，这里需要注意的一个重要前提是，如果某个兄弟姐妹看起来更受宠是因为他们由于医疗问题或危机而需要更多关注，孩子们通常是能够理解这一点的。这会稍微改变这种动态。造成伤害的不是差异本身，而是无法解释的差异。因此，偷偷摸摸的偏爱，让人觉得某一个孩子就是更容易去爱，这最终意味着我们将聚光灯转回到自己身上，开始思考：“为什么我没那么容易被爱？为什么我没有得到那样的爱？这一定是我自身的问题，是我本质上是谁的问题。”这也一定是因为他们身上有某种东西让他们比我更好，“好吧，我显然不想和他们在一起，并觉得自己糟糕透了”
about myself. Sibling conflict starts here. So maybe you're listening and relating heavily, even if you know it wasn't your parents' intention or your sibling's fault for that matter, you might just think it's just how it's meant to be. Some parents just hate certain children and I'm one of them. I think hate is a bit blunt, maybe too simple of a word, for a very complex relational pattern. This is also where parents' own unresolved issues get transferred into sibling relationships. Our parents don't welcome us into their lives only when they are in this perfect, ethereal state of being. Parenthood also doesn't automatically make people better people. We know that. We know that for sure. When a parent becomes a parent, they bring with them their own
about myself. Sibling conflict starts here. So maybe you're listening and relating heavily, even if you know it wasn't your parents' intention or your sibling's fault for that matter, you might just think it's just how it's meant to be. Some parents just hate certain children and I'm one of them. I think hate is a bit blunt, maybe too simple of a word, for a very complex relational pattern. This is also where parents' own unresolved issues get transferred into sibling relationships. Our parents don't welcome us into their lives only when they are in this perfect, ethereal state of being. Parenthood also doesn't automatically make people better people. We know that. We know that for sure. When a parent becomes a parent, they bring with them their own|||手足冲突就从这里开始了。所以，也许你在听的时候深有同感，即使你知道这并非父母的本意，也不是你兄弟姐妹的错，你可能还是会觉得“事情本该如此”。有些父母就是讨厌某些孩子，而我就是其中之一。我认为“讨厌”这个词有点直白，对于一个非常复杂的依恋模式来说，可能过于简单了。这也是父母自身未解决的问题转移到手足关系中的地方。我们的父母并不是只有在他们处于完美、空灵的状态时才欢迎我们来到他们的生活中。为人父母并不会自动让人变得更好。我们知道这一点。我们对此深信不疑。当父母成为父母时，他们随身带著自己的
history, their own wounds and fears and loyalties and relational templates from their own families. Sometimes a parent unconsciously identifies with one child and feels threatened by another. because they remind them of plot twist their own parents and their own siblings who they have their own unique relationship with that were shaped by the parents before them. You kind of see where this is going. It doesn't excuse it, but it may explain it. And I think sometimes that explanation that involves family history and investigating where this came from does provide some solace.
history, their own wounds and fears and loyalties and relational templates from their own families. Sometimes a parent unconsciously identifies with one child and feels threatened by another. because they remind them of plot twist their own parents and their own siblings who they have their own unique relationship with that were shaped by the parents before them. You kind of see where this is going. It doesn't excuse it, but it may explain it. And I think sometimes that explanation that involves family history and investigating where this came from does provide some solace.|||历史、他们自己的伤痛、恐惧、忠诚，以及来自他们自己家庭的关系模板。有时，父母会无意识地认同其中一个孩子，而对另一个孩子感到威胁。因为他们让他们想起了——剧情反转——他们自己的父母，以及他们自己的兄弟姐妹，他们与这些人有着自己独特的关系，而这些关系是由上一代父母塑造的。你大概能看出这是怎么回事了。这并不能成为借口，但它或许能解释原因。而且我认为，有时这种涉及家族史并探究根源的解释确实能提供一些心灵的慰藉。
I should also note this becomes especially relevant in families who go through a divorce or where there's parental conflict. After separation in particular, children may feel subtly or overtly pushed into alliances with each other. Or the opposite, as parents kind of fight over each child's loyalty, affection, even custody. That is a lot. Adult problems are a lot to put on a delicate sibling bond. And so when you have, you and your brothers and sisters have gone through that, the pressure spills sideways into your relationship, even if the original conflict wasn't about you two, or you three or you four. And that is why favoritism and behavior, from parents and their own issues leads to rifts and estrangement amongst siblings when it's
I should also note this becomes especially relevant in families who go through a divorce or where there's parental conflict. After separation in particular, children may feel subtly or overtly pushed into alliances with each other. Or the opposite, as parents kind of fight over each child's loyalty, affection, even custody. That is a lot. Adult problems are a lot to put on a delicate sibling bond. And so when you have, you and your brothers and sisters have gone through that, the pressure spills sideways into your relationship, even if the original conflict wasn't about you two, or you three or you four. And that is why favoritism and behavior, from parents and their own issues leads to rifts and estrangement amongst siblings when it's|||我还要指出的是，这在经历过离婚或存在父母冲突的家庭中尤其相关。特别是在分居之后，孩子们可能会在潜移默化或明目张胆的情况下被推向彼此结盟。或者相反，因为父母在争夺每个孩子的忠诚度、感情甚至是监护权。这实在太沉重了。成年人的问题对于脆弱的手足纽带来说过于沉重了。因此，当你和你的兄弟姐妹经历过这些时，压力就会横向波及到你们的关系中，即使最初的冲突并不涉及你们俩、你们仨或你们四个人。这就是为什么父母的偏心和行为以及他们自身的问题会导致兄弟姐妹之间产生裂痕和疏远，尽管这本来
not even about them. There was a 22 study examining estrangement between siblings and adulthood, and it found that these ruptures are often embedded in broader family systems that are shaped by favoritism, abuse, manipulation, disputes, and particularly parental child estrangement. Some people described in this study their sibling bond as being toxic, damaging to their mental health, slowly eroded over time by family loyalties. Others described sudden cutoffs, but it was very rare that someone turns around and goes, I don't like this person anymore. What stands out and what was consistent in this study is that it's not an isolated thing. You normally, if you are finding yourself in a place of tension or conflict with your siblings, there is probably a wider and longer
not even about them. There was a 22 study examining estrangement between siblings and adulthood, and it found that these ruptures are often embedded in broader family systems that are shaped by favoritism, abuse, manipulation, disputes, and particularly parental child estrangement. Some people described in this study their sibling bond as being toxic, damaging to their mental health, slowly eroded over time by family loyalties. Others described sudden cutoffs, but it was very rare that someone turns around and goes, I don't like this person anymore. What stands out and what was consistent in this study is that it's not an isolated thing. You normally, if you are finding yourself in a place of tension or conflict with your siblings, there is probably a wider and longer|||甚至与他们无关。2022 年有一项研究考察了成年期兄弟姐妹之间的疏远现象，发现这些决裂往往根植于更广泛的家庭系统中，这些系统由偏心、虐待、操纵、争端以及尤其是父母与子女的疏远所塑造。这项研究中的一些人将他们的手足纽带描述为有毒的、损害其心理健康的，并随着时间的推移被家庭忠诚度慢慢侵蚀。另一些人则描述了突然的断交，但很少有人会回过头来说：“我再也不喜欢这个人了。”这项研究中最突出且一致的一点是，这不是一件孤立的事情。通常情况下，如果你发现自己与兄弟姐妹处于紧张或冲突的境地，背后可能存在更广泛、更长期的
emotional history and emotional context that is shaping that, that comes a lot from the family unit. So we're going to take one more short break here, and then we're going to talk about what we can do about it and how we can rewrite our relationship with our siblings as adults and maybe give ourselves the chance to move past old hurts that not all the time, but sometimes just aren't ours to hold. Stay with us. Listen, and you're there for heart-wrenching knock-ass. And breathtaking triumph. 2026 FIFA World Cup. The knockout stage.
emotional history and emotional context that is shaping that, that comes a lot from the family unit. So we're going to take one more short break here, and then we're going to talk about what we can do about it and how we can rewrite our relationship with our siblings as adults and maybe give ourselves the chance to move past old hurts that not all the time, but sometimes just aren't ours to hold. Stay with us. Listen, and you're there for heart-wrenching knock-ass. And breathtaking triumph. 2026 FIFA World Cup. The knockout stage.|||情感历史和情感背景在起作用，而这些很大程度上来自于家庭单元。因此，我们在这里再做一次短暂的休息，接下来我们将讨论我们可以为此做些什么，以及作为成年人我们该如何重写与兄弟姐妹的关系，并或许给我们自己一个机会去放下那些不总是属于我们、但有时确实不该由我们承担的旧伤痛。请继续收听。倾听，你将见证心碎的淘汰。以及惊心动魄的胜利。2026 年国际足联世界杯。淘汰赛阶段。
Every match. Every moment. Listen on TSN Radio. Join the globe. On the road to the July 19th final. 2026 FIFA World Cup. Stream it all live on TSN Radio. Available on IHeard Radio.
Every match. Every moment. Listen on TSN Radio. Join the globe. On the road to the July 19th final. 2026 FIFA World Cup. Stream it all live on TSN Radio. Available on IHeard Radio.|||每一场比赛。每一个瞬间。在 TSN 电台收听。与全球一起。踏上通往 7 月 19 日决赛的道路。2026 年国际足联世界杯。在 TSN 电台全程直播。可在 IHeard Radio 上收听。
So after discussing the origins of sibling tension, the question kind of becomes, can we rewrite these roles? as adults and how exactly do we do that? Great news. For the first time in this whole episode, great news. I think we can totally rewrite our roles, totally rewrite the relationship that we have with our adult siblings, but that's not going to happen by ignoring that the roles we've played ever existed. A lot of healing starts with being honest about the part you were given in your family that you didn't necessarily want. Really, you have to ask yourself, what role do I play in this family. What role did I end up stepping into and how did that role impact not just me but also my sibling relationship? How did my role as the golden child or the problem child or whatever
So after discussing the origins of sibling tension, the question kind of becomes, can we rewrite these roles? as adults and how exactly do we do that? Great news. For the first time in this whole episode, great news. I think we can totally rewrite our roles, totally rewrite the relationship that we have with our adult siblings, but that's not going to happen by ignoring that the roles we've played ever existed. A lot of healing starts with being honest about the part you were given in your family that you didn't necessarily want. Really, you have to ask yourself, what role do I play in this family. What role did I end up stepping into and how did that role impact not just me but also my sibling relationship? How did my role as the golden child or the problem child or whatever|||所以在讨论完手足紧张关系的根源之后，问题就变成了：作为成年人，我们能重写这些角色吗？究竟该怎么做？好消息。整期节目中第一次听到好消息。我认为我们完全可以重写自己的角色，完全可以重写与成年兄弟姐妹的关系，但这不会通过假装我们扮演过的角色从未存在过而发生。许多疗愈始于坦诚面对你在家庭中被赋予、却未必想要的那个部分。实际上，你必须问自己：我在这个家庭中扮演什么角色？我最终踏入了什么角色，这个角色不仅对我有何影响，对我和兄弟姐妹的关系又有何影响？我作为“金童”（受宠的孩子）、“问题儿童”或是其他什么角色的身份，
push me into a specific dynamic and what role did they have to play? Because even if they were treated better than you, even if they were the favorite, that doesn't mean that they were free of any burden. Every person is trapped here in their own way. They may have been trapped in the role of the gifted child feeling that they could never express themselves, never move away from home, never fail, felt very tethered to their parents' identity. Like, they likely, even if it looks like they had a great time, they likely had the same amount of control over the label that they stepped into as you did. Like, they had no control. And so simply asking, like, why did somebody feel like they had to act this way as an important question? Sometimes recognizing that both of you were shaped by the same
push me into a specific dynamic and what role did they have to play? Because even if they were treated better than you, even if they were the favorite, that doesn't mean that they were free of any burden. Every person is trapped here in their own way. They may have been trapped in the role of the gifted child feeling that they could never express themselves, never move away from home, never fail, felt very tethered to their parents' identity. Like, they likely, even if it looks like they had a great time, they likely had the same amount of control over the label that they stepped into as you did. Like, they had no control. And so simply asking, like, why did somebody feel like they had to act this way as an important question? Sometimes recognizing that both of you were shaped by the same|||是如何把我推入某种特定的动态中的？而他们又扮演了什么角色？因为即使他们受到的对待比你好，即使他们是父母最偏爱的孩子，这并不意味着他们没有任何负担。每个人都以自己的方式被困在这里。他们可能被困在“天赋异禀的孩子”这一角色中，觉得自己永远无法表达自我、永远无法离家、永远不能失败，感觉自己与父母的身份紧紧绑在一起。比如，他们很可能——尽管看起来他们过得很开心——对贴在自己身上的标签的掌控力和你一样少。比如，他们毫无掌控力。因此，简单地问一句，比如“为什么某个人会觉得自己必须这样行事”，这是一个很重要的问题。有时认识到你们俩都是被同一个东西所塑造的，
things just in different directions, loosens a lot of the resentment that remains. Part of growing up, and again, I'm not an expert, but just my thoughts on this is that part of growing up is also accepting that children in the same family don't have the same childhood. You can live in the same house, eat at the same table, have the same parents, wear the same hammy downs, and still come away completely differently, emotionally, psychologically, socially. And what matters here is, like, if your sibling is coming to you and saying, I've experienced hurt that is making our relationship difficult, just because it wasn't your experience doesn't mean it's not true and doesn't mean that it's not impacting them deeply and doesn't necessarily mean
事情只是朝着不同的方向发展，从而化解了许多残留的怨恨。成长的一部分，再次声明，我不是专家，但我对此的想法是，成长的一部分也包括接受同一个家庭中的孩子并没有相同的童年。你可以住在同一个房子里，在同一张桌子上吃饭，有同样的父母，穿着同样的旧衣服，但在情感、心理和社会层面上，最终的结果却完全不同。这里重要的是，如果你的兄弟姐妹来找你，说他们经历过伤害，这让我们的关系变得困难，仅仅因为那不是你的经历，并不意味着它不是真的，并不意味着它没有深深地影响他们，也不一定意味着
they're blaming you for that. You may remember warmth, your other sibling remembers discomfort or hostility. One of you may have been protected because they were compliant and easygoing, or the eldest, whilst another may feel that they were punished or let down from being the youngest or having needs or speaking up. So I think moving past old hurts that have been projected onto your relationship often means letting go of the idea that there is one correct version of the family that everybody has to agree on. Sometimes there just isn't. Sometimes the truth is that each child adapted in the best way that they could with more favorable outcomes, but neither person deserved or had a say in the outcome. You also have to be open to talking about the pain in the
他们是在因此责怪你。你可能记得温暖，而你的另一个兄弟姐妹却记得不适或敌意。你们中的一个人可能因为听话随和或者是老大而受到了保护，而另一个人可能会觉得自己因为是老幺、有需求或大声说出来而受到惩罚或失望。所以我觉得，要放下投射到你们关系中的旧伤，往往意味着要放弃这样一种观念，即存在一个大家都必须认同的关于家庭的唯一正确版本。有时根本没有。有时事实是，每个孩子都以自己能做到的最好方式适应了，结果也更 फेव（有利），但没有人应得这种结果，也没有人对结果有发言权。你还得敞开心扉去谈论彼此关系中
relationship that may have come directly from either of you, from each other. It really sucks. It hurts. It's embarrassing, but something an amazing family therapist I interviewed for the podcast said to me once was, your relationship can't process poison internally, only externally. Basically, your issues need to be out in the open to be healed. They need some fresh air. And I don't think it's a question of like, how can we fix the past, but what do we actually need to have the future that we want. When you look at people who are close to their siblings, have that magical relationship, so many of us desire, what do they have, and what is the bridge to that that you can see? Typically, there's four things that is required to heal a sibling bond.
可能直接来自于你们任何一方、来自于对方的痛苦。这真的很糟糕。很伤人。这很尴尬，但我采访过的一位出色的家庭治疗师在播客中对我说过的一句话是，你们的关系无法在内部消化毒素，只能在外部消化。基本上，你的问题需要公开才能治愈。它们需要一些新鲜空气。我不认为这就像我们如何修复过去的问题，而是我们实际上需要什么来拥有我们想要的未来。当你看到那些与兄弟姐妹关系亲密、拥有我们许多人渴望的那种神奇关系的人时，他们拥有什么，你能看到通往那里的桥梁是什么？通常，治愈兄弟姐妹的纽带需要四件事。
Accountability, grace, curiosity, and communication. Maybe a better question then, like, what do I want my future relationship to look like would be, how do we get those things? And what would a healthier version of this relationship be like just even an inch. For some people, if we go through that list, it means I need you to say sorry. For other people, it means I need you to be curious about what I went through, or I need you to have some grace about how I'm trying to change. And maybe for you, it's like, I just actually can't be around this person. Again, like, just because your family doesn't mean the relationship is immune to the things that a lot of relationships contain. which is toxicity, hurt, pain, and an inability to forgive and an inability to move on.
问责、包容、好奇心和沟通。那么，一个更好的问题，比如，我希望我未来的关系是什么样子的，那就是，我们如何得到这些东西？这个关系的更健康的版块会是什么样子的，哪怕只进步一英寸。对有些人来说，如果我们看完这份清单，这意味着我需要你道歉。对另一些人来说，这意味着我需要你对我的经历感到好奇，或者我需要你对我的改变方式保持一些包容。也许对你来说，就像，我实际上无法和这个人在一起。同样地，仅仅因为你们是家人，并不意味着这段关系就能免疫许多关系所包含的问题，也就是有毒性、伤害、痛苦，以及无法原谅和无法向前看。
It might also just mean that, like, we can, just being honest about your relationship, we can be friends, we can have this sibling bond, but we can only have it every now and again. Like, we can't have it all the time. I don't feel happy, safe around them all the time. At Christmas, maybe, in a controlled environment, maybe, but maybe just will never be repaired. The damage is done. characters were assigned. Like, the past cannot be rewritten, but that doesn't mean you're not siblings, and it doesn't mean that, like, you can't reminisce occasionally, see each other occasionally,
这也可能意味着，对于我们的关系我们要诚实，我们可以做朋友，我们可以有这种兄弟姐妹的纽带，但我们只能偶尔拥有它。就像，我们不能一直拥有它。我并不总是觉得和他们在一起很开心、很安全。在圣诞节，也许吧，在一个受控的环境里，也许吧，但也许永远也无法修复了。损害已经造成了。角色已经分配了。就像，过去是无法重写的，但这并不意味着你们不是兄弟姐妹，也不意味着你们不能偶尔怀念过去，偶尔见面，
have some part of them and their lives intersect with you. And I think this is where moving past old hurts really begins in realizing that you do not have to keep living the same story of your relationship. So to summarize, what has been a big episode about sibling rivalry and tension in adult sibling relationships. First, the sibling relationship, as we know, stands alone. It's one of the most unique we can have. In many ways, conflict and rivalry is part of the fabric of that relationship. It occasionally has some benefits. You know, you learn a lot. You model what is good and bad behavior. It's also evolutionary. It's kind of hardwired into us. But it can become really emotionally damaging and threatening when it becomes
让他们生命中的一部分与你交织。我想这就是放下旧伤的真正开始，意识到你不需要继续活在你们关系的同一个故事里。总而言之，这是一集关于成年兄弟姐妹关系中的竞争和紧张的大型节目。首先，如我们所知，兄弟姐妹关系是独一无二的。它是我们能拥有的最独特的羁绊之一。在许多方面，冲突和竞争是这种关系结构的一部分。它偶尔会有一些好处。你知道，你学到了很多。你塑造了什么是好行为，什么是坏行为。这也是进化的结果。它有点深深烙印在我们体内。但当它变成
about things that are larger than petty disputes and becomes centered on a very real parental favoritism, assigned roles, being placed in the middle of parental disputes you didn't ask to be a part of. In these situations, the sibling dynamic becomes a casualty of those things. And that can mean when you look around at other people's relationships with their brothers and sisters, it just doesn't look the same because you guys have had a different past that's gotten you to this point. I do think there is hope. Sibling relationships have time and time again shown that they can be repaired by honestly separating ourselves from childhood roles or conflicts as much as we possibly can, not always, but as much as the
超越小摩擦、演变成非常现实的父母偏爱、被分配的角色、被卷入你并不想参与的父母纠纷的中心时，它就会变得非常具有情感破坏性和威胁性。在这些情况下，兄弟姐妹的动态就成了这些事情的牺牲品。这意味着，当你环顾其他人与兄弟姐妹的关系时，它看起来就是不一样，因为你们有着不同的过去才走到这一步。我认为还是有希望的。兄弟姐妹的关系一次又一次地证明，只要我们尽最大可能将自己与童年的角色或冲突分离开来，虽然不总是这样，但只要
situation requires us to, and just being curious about how our siblings' childhood was different to ours, even if it occurred in the same environment and family, and being curious about what you actually want from each other and what actually needs to be said and what actually needs to be changed. I think we are very good at knowing we might need to change for partners, friends, for a workplace, but in our family, it feels harder because it's kind of like, oh, just accept me as I am. Isn't that your job? Like, families are meant to love each other no matter what.
情况需要我们这样做，并且对我们的兄弟姐妹的童年与我们的童年有何不同保持好奇心，即使它发生在相同的环境和家庭中，并对你们彼此真正想要什么、什么真正需要说出来、什么真正需要改变保持好奇心，关系是可以修复的。我认为我们非常擅长知道我们可能需要为伴侣、朋友、工作场所而改变，但在我们的家庭中，这感觉更难，因为这有点像，哦，就按原样接受我吧。这难道不是你的工作吗？就像，家人本来就应该无条件地爱彼此。
You can have that perspective, but does it align with the larger objective you have, which is to have the closeness that you so want with your siblings? because if you want to get that, you do have to kind of dig through some of the same issues and problems that every other relationship, platonic, romantic, familiar or otherwise is going to have. So that concludes our first standalone episode on siblings in like almost 500 episodes of the podcast. I sincerely hope it was helpful. Sorry it took me so long to get here. I also want to say, obviously, within this, there are so many other unique dynamics and things
你可以有这种观点，但它是否符合你更大的目标，也就是和你想要的兄弟姐妹保持亲密关系？因为如果你想实现这一点，你确实必须深入挖掘其他所有人际关系——柏拉图式的、浪漫的、家庭的或其他任何关系——都会遇到的同样的问题和麻烦。因此，我们的兄弟姐妹主题第一集独立节目到此结束，这也是这档播客近500集以来的第一次。我真诚地希望它对你有所帮助。抱歉我花了这么长时间才做到这一点。我还想说，显然，在这其中，还有许多其他独特的动态和事情
time to discuss. So if this didn't apply to you, please seek out other resources and know that this is not the holy grail of accounts on sibling rivalry. People may have better things to say, things that may be aligned with your perspective, more. If there is something that we didn't discuss that you would like a follow-up episode on, feel free to leave a comment. Feel free to DM me on Instagram. It's at that psychology podcast.
需要时间来讨论。所以，如果这不适用于你，请寻找其他资源，并知道这不是关于兄弟姐妹竞争的终极准则。人们可能会有更好的说法，可能更符合你的视角。如果我们有什么没有讨论到，而你希望有一期后续节目，请随时留言。欢迎在Instagram上私信我。账号是那个心理学播客。
You can also follow us there just to learn more, not just about sibling dynamics, but everything in general about the psychology of your 20s. Also a reminder that we have a substack. We have episodes on Netflix if you want to peruse or browse those in the meantime. I want to say a big thank you to our researcher Libby Cobbett for her research help and assistance with this episode. She did some amazing digging into developmental psychology papers and articles and we are very grateful for her. But that concludes the episode. Until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself, especially if you're going through a sibling
你也可以在那里关注我们，以了解更多信息，不仅是关于兄弟姐妹的动态，还有关于你20多岁心理学的方方面面。还要提醒大家，我们有一个Substack。如果你想在此期间浏览或查阅，我们有关于Netflix的剧集。我要向我们的研究员莉比·科贝特（Libby Cobbett）表示衷心的感谢，感谢她对本期节目的研究帮助和协助。她对发展心理学的论文和文章进行了一些了不起的挖掘，我们非常感谢她。但本期节目到此结束。下次再见前，请注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点，尤其是如果你正在经历兄弟姐妹
rival real conflict right now. We will talk very, very soon. This is an IHeart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
之间的激烈竞争或冲突。我们很快就会再聊。这是一个IHeart播客，保证由真人制作。这期节目暂时还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。